♪ (intro music) ♪
♪ (music) ♪
Have you ever wanted to give your app
a fancy animated header
that changes appearance as you scroll
or maybe even disappears?
You can with SliverAppBar!
SliverAppBar is used with CustomScrollView
to provide custom scroll behavior
for the app bar.
The word "sliver" may give you the shivers,
but it's really just a funny word
for a portion of a scrollable area.
You can think of slivers
as a lower level interface
providing finer grain control
on implementing scrollable areas.
The flexibleSpace parameter
goes hand in hand
with the expandedHeight parameter.
You can set both for a different height
and appearance of your app bar
when it is expanded to its full size.
Set the floating parameter to true
to make the app bar reappear
when you scroll down,
even if you haven't reached
the top of the list.
For more info on SliverAppBar,
CustomScrollView,
and all the other Flutter widgets,
head over to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪